[Music]
my new company v3 big bouncy boobies all
right who's got the biggest titties
flat-chested know it get the [ __ ] up get
the [ __ ] out Zoe
Kiana you get that ass but get that [ __ ]
you take before we call the big teddy
Nikki you look like you're from tumblr I
despise you I hate your guts but
business is business and your higher
Nikki Bella you're in okay we got Lyle
on e she's Asian foot flat chest not on
it why do you show up get up all right
Zoe Zoe we had this talk before it's
time to hire another one okay we got
Lillian
she's teen tattoos [ __ ] up [ __ ] off
Lillian why is it so hard why we're
hiring her you better get some implants
all right what's her cup size be that
finally from the gosh Candace you're in
[ __ ] sake you're all useless
one dollar per hour Kiana you're in
Tiffany one dollar an hour
Tiffany you're in you're in now buy me
shoes oh my god Zoe how many times are
you trying how many [ __ ] times I
gotta tell you so we get the [ __ ] out
and stop wasting my time you got zero
potential zero hey Tiffany wear this
butt plug while you go shopping
[Music]
but plug right Zoey you want him working
this business so hard
here take this butt plug why me some
cigarettes [ __ ] up I'm gonna have to
hire my last skirt Marlena
but she said naturally but ain't nothing
natural about that girl oh my god that
money
finally finally I'm rolling the pimpest
miss my mom would be so proud of me
right now the way I handled would
approve of this video please jump in
Audio bump it through the rows and you
know we all love
you